>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> All right, all right.
I think that you're
ready for our next author
because Miss Agra Deedy
has written a book called
"The Rooster Who Would
Not Be Quiet."
She was born in Havana, Cuba.
And when she was still a kid,
she moved with her family
to the United States.
They moved here as refugees.
They settled in Decatur, Georgia,
which is where she lives today.
Carmen grew up loving stories.
In fact, she has said,
I cannot remember a time
when I did not love stories.
One of her favorite books as
a child was "Charlotte's Web."
And Kate Dicamillo talked about
"Charlotte's Web" earlier today.
That's a common theme.
Because she has a deep
love for animals.
And her latest book combines
that love for animals
with her superb storytelling and
a message of bravery and courage.
Miss Deedy will sign copies of
her book from 1:30 to 2:30 PM.
Please allow me to introduce
Miss Carmen Agra Deedy.
[ Applause ]
>> Carmen Agra Deedy: They're
the ones that make us sound good.
Thank you so much.
Hola.
>> Multiple Speakers: Hola.
>> Carmen Agra Deedy: That
was kind of pitiful, people.
Hola.
>> Multiple Speakers: Hola.
>> Carmen Agra Deedy: And I grew up
in the South, so it's hola y'all.
When I was a little girl, I came to
the little town of Decatur, Georgia.
And I know you all just heard
that bit, but if you didn't, well,
it bears repeating because it was,
as for many refugees and immigrants,
it can be a very interesting
childhood.
It's like when the Hmong
refugee end up in like Wisconsin.
Well, Cubans in Decatur, Georgia.
When I was 6 years
old, I started school.
And I want to tell you just about
that much about that experience.
I remember my mother
braiding my hair.
And when I was done,
[foreign language spoken].
Why I got go to go
to stinking school?
I'm just fine right here.
How you going to do
stuff without me, huh?
Because I was my mother's helper.
And my mother said,
[foreign language spoken].
You don't have to help me;
you have to help yourself.
You have to go to school.
[Foreign language spoken],
needs no translation.
And then we walked, we
walked the block and a half,
down the broken old sideways,
which every town had back then,
along a line of sweet poplars
and up the tired, well,
they were stone steps,
but they were worn.
Other reluctant leather soled shoes
had preceded mine by many decades.
When we walked in,
we took a hard right.
The old water fountain, had
the rust stain down the middle,
black and white checkered linoleum.
And there standing next to a
door, this is the boring part,
stay with me, was a enormous door.
There were construction
paper autumn leaves.
The sentinel that stood by this door
was a long woman, kind of gamey,
hair sprayed into a
perfect football helmet.
It was 1966.
She was beautifully upholstered
like a couch in oak or tweed,
kitten heels, Agnes Scott ring.
I didn't know what it was at
the time, but I would learn.
And when she greeted us, she
greeted us in the dulcet tones,
so familiar in that time.
Well, how are you, Miss Carmen?
We're so glad you're here, precious.
The whole class is going
to learn about Cuba today.
My mother looked at me, this
is [foreign word spoken].
You can't leave me here.
You don't even know this woman.
My mother was mortified.
I am so sorry.
Let me talk to her for a moment.
And then my mom pulled me
over to that water fountain.
Listen to me.
I'm listening to you.
[Foreign language spoken],
you behave yourself
and do not make the nice lady crazy,
which opened up a whole
world of possibility.
And then my mother
squeezed my hands.
And that's when I realized that
her hands were as moist as my own.
She kissed the top of my head
and said, I will be back at 3:00.
You better.
And then, as she walked away,
she called back, I love you.
I can tell.
And she was gone.
Click, click, click, click.
And I turned back.
Don't worry, sugar,
said my new teacher.
You're going to love it here.
I don't think so.
This didn't look promising to me.
I knew home.
I knew my mother.
I was a kid who was refugeed at 3.
I wasn't big on change.
My new teacher, back then,
they didn't have ESL.
They didn't prepare teachers
for this sort of thing.
Student and teacher,
it was sink or swim.
And there were a lot of drownings.
She leaned low and said,
Carmen, now prepare yourself.
And that's when I figured I'd
better stop this right now.
Some of you children know
sometimes you just have
to get straightened out, you know,
everything out from the get go,
as they say in the South.
And I talked to my teacher
and I said, wait, wait,
wait, lady, listen, listen.
My name is not lady.
You're not a lady?
No, I am a lady, but
my name is not lady.
My name is Miss Burns.
It was marvelous that she could
get that much air in her mouth
and it would synthesize
in such a strange way.
And I said, Miss Burns.
No, Burns.
Burns. Never mind.
See, that's the problem right there.
That's what I was trying
to tell you.
Carmen, we don't -- No see, Miss
Burns, my name is not Carmen.
It's Carmen.
Those little pencil thin eyebrows
flew up like little apostrophes.
She tried to run her fingers through
her hair, but it'd been like,
you know, it was like a helmet.
And she shook herself for a moment
as if to shake out the confusion.
And then this marvelous woman took
a deep breath, worried her lip
for a minute, leaned low.
I could smell the evening in Paris.
And she said, putting that
Spanish name in her southern mouth.
It's a true story, so I'm so sorry.
Things are going to happen
the way they'd happened.
Carmen. You got hair in your nose.
She straightened up.
I think I heard her garter snap.
And she said, that's
enough, Miss Carmen.
My mama uses the little scissors.
That's enough.
I don't need to hear
what your mother said.
Give me your hand.
She took my hand, this
wonderful woman,
and we walked into first grade with
all the attendant sights and smells.
There was a blackboard that was.
There were enormous windows, and
those windows had deep seals.
They would soon hold
little paper cups with seeds
that would never ever grow.
There was a coat closet.
There were chairs in tidy rows,
and there was an enormous
ocean of a desk.
And next to it, a little tiny desk.
All the children watched.
This is 1966 for those of
you who know your history.
They weren't sure what
to do with us.
So they sort of just
let us wander in
and they'd figure out
where to put us.
The children looked at me.
I looked at them.
Can I go home now?
Stop. Girls and boys,
this is our new student.
I told you about her today.
Remember, we talked about Cuba.
We were late, of course, which is
why the other children had already
learned about me before I'd arrived.
And for those of you that are more
politically correct than I am,
I have to tell you,
I love my people,
but we tell time by a sundial.
And so, it was no surprise
that by the time I
arrived, an hour had passed.
And all the children
were expecting me.
And when she had me
introduce myself,
my name is Carmen, I
saw their lips move.
Now what do we do?
Follow me.
Go back to your work, please.
I wrote on the board
what I want you to copy.
Continue your work.
They all had D'Nealian paper.
It was standard issue.
Still is in a lot of schools.
We went to her desk.
And as she pointed to my new place
in the classroom, I didn't like it.
Children, sometimes you
just have to speak up.
Excuse me.
Excuse me, Miss Burns.
What's wrong?
How come I got to sit over here?
That's your desk for a while,
until you get used to class.
Yeah, but how come all the other
kids are sitting over there?
I love codes.
Well, darling, because
you're special.
That means I'm stupid.
No, we don't use that
word in first grade.
Can we use it -- No,
we don't use it at all.
See, the kids are laughing and
y'all are like, oh, she said stupid.
And look, the kids up here,
they're like, oh, yeah.
They love that word.
It's a horrible word,
but they love it.
Sometimes they pick
it up like a rock.
I looked at my teacher and
said, but it doesn't --
And then she just seemed
so frustrated.
She did everything but pearl clutch.
And then she said two words.
And girls and boys and big
people, I mean, you're here too,
but you're sort of -- Well,
you're incidental to this story.
She said, Overton Crooms.
I thought she was cursing.
And then a boy jumped up out of the
front row, and he was a big kid.
He'd seen first grade
more than once.
This boy had tenure.
He had overalls on.
His hair was slick bad.
He had on a pair of work boots,
and he kind of ambled over
and he said, yes ma'am, Miss Burns.
Please take this desk and
put it in front of your own.
Thank you very much.
Yes, ma'am.
He looked at me and
went, and I went ha ha.
He's cute.
He put the desk down.
I sat down.
Miss Burns started to speak.
And as soon as she began to
speak, I couldn't hear anything
because phonemes for
me were never clear.
So remember Charlie Brown?
Well, that's the way
I heard language.
I'm an aural dyslexic.
It would be another -- I was
28 before I was diagnosed.
All I knew is I couldn't
understand her.
And meanwhile, next to my right ear,
a voice had grown quite intimate.
Hey, girl.
What? Girl, say your name again.
What? Your name, fool.
Say your name again.
Carmen. I heard him.
And I said, oh yeah,
say your name again.
This boy goes Overton Crooms.
Yeah, you laughing at me?
I don't think so.
Rather than be offended,
he did what you just did.
He started to snort and laugh.
And I looked over and his
shoulders were down on the desk
and he was jiggling up and down.
And by now, guess whose
attention we'd garnered?
This is storytelling,
the interactive art.
That is not rhetorical.
Who is coming our way,
do you suppose?
Miss Burns.
Oh, yes, yes, with those
long, stork-like legs.
She is cutting right
across the classroom.
And she is shouting, Miss Agra, Mr.
Crooms, is there something you would
like to share with
the rest of the class.
Now you people know the answer
to that, which is no, nothing.
You would not have survived
in Miss Burns' first grade,
let me just tell you right now.
But see, Overton knew
because, like I said,
he was a veteran of first grade.
He didn't say a word.
What do I say?
Oh, no. We doing fine.
You go back to doing
whatever you was doing.
I was air born, gently, of course.
She took me by the elbow.
She marched me outside.
She sat me in a little chair.
How she knew, I don't know.
It seemed to have just
been waiting for me.
And she said, you sit out here,
you think about what you've done.
Children, when I was a child,
parents loved to say
things like that to us.
And you know when you've done
something kind of rotten,
but you really enjoyed it?
They shouldn't tell you that.
I sat in my chair and I began
to sing because I was bored.
And I'd just recently seen
a movie about Cinderella
in our black and white console.
And so, in my Cuban accent, I song,
in my own little corner, in my --
Inside the classroom, a voice
said, most sternly, no singing.
[ Humming ]
No humming.
[ Whistling ]
She was out there and
on me in a tick.
She lifted me out of that
chair and she said, children,
we're going outside,
which is what they did
when they didn't want to kill you.
And so, she gathered
up these first graders.
And we tried to make a
line, but we couldn't.
We were a herd of cats.
And so, she finally, in some form
of a herd, she got us outside.
And we went out to the playground,
which was an amazing thing
back then, the playground.
In Georgia, it was
packed red Georgia clay
that would kill a child.
And on top of this, they put
metal playground equipment.
And on that equipment, the children
played, and some of them didn't.
It was Darwinian.
If you survived the
playground, you deserved to live
and your line would go on.
If not, like the Carruthers,
you went down on the monkey bars
and they never saw you again.
Look at the kids.
They're like, is that true.
No, well. All the girls
went this way.
All the boys went that
way, and I was by myself
because I looked funny,
I talked funny,
and my mother dressed me funny.
That's what happens to refugees.
Don't for feel sorry for me.
My life turned out okay.
Meanwhile, back in the
story, hello, tree.
You are my friend and
I shall call you tree.
Because, right, like we
make friends where we can.
So who sashays up?
He was a sashayer from
way back, Overton.
It's a thing, sashay.
He said, arms akimbo.
Great word, akimbo, right.
Hope you're listening
for these words.
What you doing hugging that tree.
You look like a idiot.
He was plain spoken.
I said, it's my friend.
Just stop that.
Stop it. How come you ain't
playing with them girls.
Well, I wasn't about to
tell him they didn't ask me.
Please, a little pride.
I don't want to.
They didn't ask you, huh?
You got nothing else to do kid?
And then he told me that he
was going to teach me something
and every kid on that playground
was going to want to play
with me, the girls anyway.
Oh yeah, right.
You got fairy dust?
I got something better.
Follow me.
I followed him.
Went around behind the sycamore
tree and he said, put your hands up.
And I said, whoa, it's a hold up.
No. He didn't live in
my neighborhood clearly.
Those are free.
And he started to sing, in
dulcet southern tones, see,
see my playmate, come
out and play with me,
and bring your dollies three.
Climb up my apple tree.
Do you remember it?
Slide down -- Come on.
Slide down my rain barrel
onto my cellar floor.
And we'll be -- what?
Jolly friends forever more, more.
Oh, man, it took about 20
times, but I learned it.
See, see my playmate.
What are you doing?
You don't dance.
It's the way of my people, baby.
Finally, he just said
go get them, get them.
Well, I ran down there.
I found those girls.
I taught them see, see my playmate.
And they played with one another.
Hey, I can play.
I taught you.
I marched right back.
Hello, tree.
What happened?
I shrugged.
He scratched the back of his head.
Now it hasn't occurred
to me at this point,
and it probably most likely
hasn't occurred to you
as you hear this story, to think why
Overton isn't playing with the boys.
Well, you see, the two border
dwellers had found one another.
And he said, want to
go on the monkey bars.
Monkey, no, no, [foreign
language spoken].
I don't even know what you
just said, but come on.
It's fun. Well, the monkey
bars were on the far end
of the playground, near the woods.
There was another place to play.
Half the time, we didn't come
back and they never looked for us.
I know. I'm sorry, children.
You will never experience
a feral childhood.
And I for one want to
apologize to you for that.
You all should clap.
Do you remember feral
childhood, people?
You'd come home when the
streetlights come on.
We hoped you lived.
Well, we were out there
and we were swinging
on the monkey bars
and it's fabulous.
And I have like three
minutes to close up,
so let me tell you what happened.
We never heard the eternal call
of teachers, [clapping] right.
Even back in the dark ages when
the stones were soft, kids,
when I was kid, that
was how they called you.
Well, it was the first
day of school.
I didn't know, and
Overton didn't care.
And so, Mr. Overton, Miss Carmen.
Now we're down to Miss first
names and Mr. first names.
We fell to the ground.
I lost a shoe.
I was digging around for it.
She stood in front, towered
really, casting a long shadow.
Miss Carmen, did you
hear me calling you?
Well, I didn't know
what to say, y'all.
I figured I'd just use a strategy
that had worked for
my mother before.
I think you'll understand.
I don't speak no English.
I thought I saw her laughing.
She just bit down on her tongue
and she said, move, move.
And she gave me a little
shove, none too gentle.
And as I walked away, ran
really, I heard over my shoulder,
so wonderful, and you Mr.
Overton, what is your excuse.
And that precious boy said, I
don't speak no English neither.
And there were two little chairs
outside Miss Burns' classroom
that afternoon.
It was wonderful.
I even taught him in my own
little corner, in my own.
Why am I telling you this story?
Because it's a story.
It's a story about
voice, the irrepressible,
exhausting voices children
can have, the voice all of us
in this room once had, the ones
many of us buried long ago.
And in the name of
civilization, I'm all for it.
We wouldn't have the grand
buildings, the laws, the civility.
But there's something else
that comes with voice.
Do you remember when
it was strong and true?
Who would you be if you hadn't
become the person everyone
around you eventually
believed you were?
What would you speak?
What would you dream?
My new book, "The Rooster
Who Would Not Be Quiet,"
is about a little village who,
for reasons that seem
practical, outlawed singing.
It became very quiet, until a noisy
little rooster who knew nothing
of their laws, as most children
don't when they first arrive
into our civilized society, he
began to sing qui-qui-ri-qui.
And he never lost his voice.
So here's the thing.
If you have it, keep it.
If you lost it, be of strong heart.
It's never gone.
It's still in there.
And to say goodbye, please say
with me, on the count of three,
qui-qui-ri-qui, Spanish
onomatopoeia for cock a doodle doo.
One two three, qui-qui-ri-qui.
Check out my new book.
I won't tell you the end, but
children, the rooster turns
out all right in the end.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.